YOUR GOVERNMENT IS MERCIFULLY
COMING TO AN END.
WITH MARKET MAYBE SOON TO BE
SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE HOUSE
MINORITY LEADER KEVIN
McCARTHY.
THAT MAYBE THAT LAST TIME I
INTRODUCE YOU AS THAT.
CONGRATULATIONS ON WHAT IS A
HUGE VICTORY FOR THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE BECAUSE THIS IS THE ONLY
AVENUE GOVERNMENT NOW WHERE WE
CAN PUT A CHECK AND A BALANCE ON
THE BIDEN IMMIGRATION AND THESE
NEW GREEN NEW DEAL THEM BECAUSE.
LET'S FIRST TALK ABOUT YOU WON
THAT NOMINATION INSIDE YOUR
PARTY CAUCUS.
YOU HAVE TO HAVE 218 VOTES TO BE
THE SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE.
A SMALL MARGIN.
WILL REPUBLICANS PUT THEIR EGOS
ASIDE?
WILL THEY WORK TOGETHER?
WILL THEY FOLLOW UP ON THE
COMMITMENTS TO AMERICA?
WILL THAT USE THE POWER OF
SUBPOENA AND THE POWER OF THE
PURSE?
>> Congressman McCarthy: I
BELIEVE SO, SEAN AND WE NEED TO
WORK TOGETHER BECAUSE YOU ARE
RIGHT.
WE ARE THE ONLY -- THAT CAN STOP
THIS DISASTROUS BIDEN AGENDA.
THINK FOR ONE MOMENT.
IT IS OFFICIAL.
ONE PARTY DEMOCRAT RULE IN
WASHINGTON IS FINISHED.
WE HAVE FIRED NANCY PELOSI.
WE HAVE WORKED HARD TO EARN THIS
AGENDA.
YOU WERE RIGHT.
WE WORKED VERY HARD ON GETTING
THE MAJORITY.
WE PUT THE COMMITMENT TO MAKE
OUT THERE.
WE TOLD THE AMERICAN FOR
EXECUTIVE WHAT WE WOULD DO AND
THINK ABOUT IMPACT 218th SEE
THAT WAS CALLED SENATE WAS
CONGRESSMAN MIKE GARCIA.
THE FORMER NAVAL ACADEMY F-18
PILOT.
THIS IS LOS ANGELES CLIPPER THIS
IS A SEAT THAT JOE BIDEN CARRIED
BY 13 POINTS.
AND WE WON IT.
AND WE STILL GOT MORE GOOD NEWS
TONIGHT.
MADERA JUST CAME BACK AND WE
COUNT FOR THE CALIFORNIA 13th
AND JOHN DUARTE HAD JUST GONE UP
BY 900 VOTES.
WE GOT ABOUT FOUR MORE SEATS OUT
THERE POSSIBLY THAT WE CAN WIN.
BUT THE ONE THING I KNOW IN
WASHINGTON, WE DON'T HANDICAP US
OUT IN SMALL, MEDIUM, AND
LARGE-SIZE.
IT IS ONE SIZE GRAVEL.
THE ABILITY TO THE SUBPOENA AND
HOLD THIS GOVERNMENT
ACCOUNTABLE, SECURE THIS BORDER,
FIGHT TO MAKE ENERGY INDEPENDENT
COULD GET THE PARENTS A SAY IN
THEIR KIDS' EDUCATION AND
ACTUALLY LOOKED WITH THE DOJ IS
DOING AND THAT DHS IS DOING AND
OTHERS AND THAT IS EXACTLY WHAT
WE ARE GOING TO DUDES ON DAY ONE
IN THIS HOUSE.
WE WILL REPEAL 87,000 NEW IRS.
>> Sean: YOU WOULD HAVE TO POWER
TO DO THAT BECAUSE YOU HAVE THE
POWER OF THE PURSE?
>> Congressman McCarthy: THAT IS
EXACTLY RIGHT AND WE WILL USE
THE POWER OF THE PURSE.
SIZE OF OUR DEBT HAS GOT TO
STOP.
WE HAVE GOT TO ACTUALLY FOCUS IN
WHAT WE DID LISTENING TO THE
EMERGENT PUBLIC.
YOU HAVE TO MAKE AN ECONOMY THAT
IS STRONG.
THEY ARE HURTING BECAUSE OF
INFLATION.
WE GOT TO CLICK ON THIS WASTEFUL
WASHINGTON SPENDING.
WE GOT TO MAKE OURSELVES ENERGY
INDEPENDENT.
NOT JUST ENERGY INDEPENDENT LAS.
LET'S MAKE CHINA DEPENDENT ON
OUR NATURAL GAS.
LET'S SECURE OUR BORDERS SO OUR
CHILDREN ARNOLD ARE BEING KILLED
BY FENTANYL EVERY SINGLE DAY.
LET'S MAKE SURE WE STOP
DEFUNDING THE POLICE AND START
FUNDING THEM.
LET'S MAKE SURE PARENTS HAVE THE
PARENTS BILL OF RIGHTS A SAY IN
THEIR KIDS' EDUCATION LET'S MAKE
SURE GOVERNMENT IS HELD
ACCOUNTABLE.
YOU HAVE TO CONGRESSMAN WHO ARE
GOING TO LEAD THE CHARGE FOR
MAKING SURE GOVERNMENT IS HELD
ACCOUNTABLE.
>> Sean: ON KNOW WE HAVE CARBS
BEEN CALMER COMING UP AND HE IS
ON THE HOUSE OVERSIGHT
COMMITTEE.
HE SAYS HE IS READY TO SUBPOENA
HUNTER BIDEN.
JIM JORDAN IS NOW GOING TO BE
LOOKING INTO IT WAS NOT THE FBI
HAS BEEN POLITICIZED.
THAT IS AN INFESTATION.
WE ALSO HAVE INFESTATIONS INTO
THE NIH AND POSSIBLE FUNDING TO
THE ECO-ALLIANCE OF THE WUHAN
VIROLOGY LAB.
DID AMERICAN TAXPAYERS HELP PAY
FOR COVID-19?
WILL THAT BE PART OF THE
INVESTIGATION?
>> Congressman McCarthy: WE WANT
TO KNOW THE ORIGINS OF WHERE
COVID BEGAN SO WE NEVER HAVE
THAT HAPPEN AGAIN.
HOW DID IT GET THERE?
WE WANT TO KNOW WHAT HAPPENED IN
THE LAST 60 DAYS OF AFGHANISTAN.
WHY DIDN'T THE PRESIDENT LISTEN
TO THE MILITARY?
CREATING 13 NEW GOLD STAR
FAMILIES THAT NEVER SHOULD HAVE
TAKEN PLACE.
WE HAVE GOT A NUMBER OF WAYS.
WHETHER THE DOJ THERE AFTER
PARENTS AND CALL THEM
TERRORISTS?
HOW CAN WE HAVE A SECRETARY OF
HOMELAND CALLING THAT AT THIS
BORDER IS SECURE WHEN YOU HAVE
MORE THAN 2.7 INDIVIDUALS
ILLEGALLY COMING ACROSS?
ARE THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE ON THE
TERRORIST WATCH LIST COMING INTO
AMERICA?
WHAT DO THEY HAVE PLANNED?
WHO ARE THEY TALKING TO?
AND WHY ARE THEY HERE?
THAT IS JUST THE START.
>> Sean: LET ME ASK YOU THIS
QUESTION AND IT HAS TO DO -- AND
WE SAW THE PARROT THAT NANCY
PELOSI HAD WITH THE SIMILAR
MAJORITY.
>> Congressman McCarthy: SAME
SIZE MAJORITY.
>> Sean: OKAY.
MY QUESTION TO YOU IS THIS.
AND I KNOW EVERYBODY HAS THEIR
OWN AGENDA.
BUT THERE ARE A LOT OF 80, 20
ISSUES, 90 ISSUES AND LOOK, I
DON'T KNOW WHAT IS GOING TO
HAPPEN WITHIN THE CAUCUS.
BUT ANY CONGRESSMAN WHO BECAUSE
AN AWFUL LOT OF TROUBLE, IF YOU
ARE THE SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE,
THE ONLY ADMONITION I HAVE
BECAUSE OF THE REPUBLICANS IF
THEY DON'T WORK AS A UNIT THEY
ARE NOT GOING TO SUCCEED.
THEY WILL LIVE AND DIE TOGETHER.
AND I THINK IF YOU STAY ON THOSE
ISSUES, ARE YOU CONFIDENT THAT
THE CAUCUS WILL HOLD STRONG
TOGETHER AND RALLY AROUND THE
ISSUES THAT THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
ENTRUSTED YOU WITH WHEN YOU'VE
MADE YOUR COMMITMENTS TO
AMERICA?
>> Congressman McCarthy: WE WORK
TOGETHER IN THIS COMMITMENT TO
AMERICA.
FOR THE LAST YEAR AND A HALF.
WE WATCHED IT.
TO MAKE AN ECONOMY THAT IS
STRONG.
THAT NATION THAT IS SAFE.
THE FUTURE THAT IS BUILT ON
FREEDOM AND A GOVERNMENT IS HELD
A CANNIBAL.
WE JUST HAD AN ISSUE WITH A
PRIMARY WITH MORE THAN 84% OF
THE CONFERENCE I WAS ABLE -- WE
HAD THAT DEBATE.
WITH NOW IS THE TIME TO MOVE
FORWARD TO SAVE THIS NATION.
IF IT WORKS FOR THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
WE HAVE TO WORK AS A TEAM WORK
WE WILL LOSE AS INDIVIDUALS AND
I BELIEVE THIS CONFERENCE WILL
RALLY TOGETHER.
BECAUSE WE WILL HAVE A TOUGH
TIME.
BUT IF WE LISTEN AND OR HARDER
TOGETHER, WE CAN'T MAKE THE NEXT
CENTURY THE AMERICAN CENTURY.
WE WERE THE ONLY ONES HOLDING
AGAINST THIS DISASTROUS AGENDA
BY JOE BIDEN.
I THINK FOR ONE MOMENT.
FOUR IS, I WAS ELECTED.
WE HAD JUST LOST THE MAJORITY.
LESS THAN 200 SEATS.
FOR THE LAST TWO ELECTION
CYCLES, WE HAD THAT NOTHING BUT
WIN EXCEEDS.
THE REPUBLICANS IN THE SENATE
LOST.
THE REPUBLICANS AND THE
GOVERNMENT LESS BUT IT IS A LEAP
IN THE HOUSE.
WE ARE THE LAST LINE OF DEFENSE
SO WE CAN'T TAKE THIS PERSONAL.
WE CAN'T GO OUT AND MAKE OUR OWN
INDIVIDUAL IDEAS.
WE NEED TO WORK AS A TEAM FOR
THE SAKE OF THIS NATION AND I
ASKED ANYBODY THAT JOIN WITH US.
YOU LOOK AT THIS NEW FRESHMEN
CLASS.
LOOK AT THIS REPUBLICAN PARTY.
WE WILL LISTEN TO THE AMERICAN
PUBLIC.
WE WILL LEAD FOR THE MAC IN
PUBLIC AS WELL.
JOIN WITH US.
WE WILL WORK WITH AND WITH THAT
WANT TO MAKE AMERI